your first dip back at the house but you  come back with not just your family on  your mind but everyone in your  neighborhood  yeah I mean obviously it's a great  community it's a community wonderful  people and you know a lot of parents who  school those kids go to the same school  is my kid and you know it's just  devastating but coming back here there's  a lot of hope I see how many homes are  standing and I see you know a lot of  positive things there's a lot of people  glad to evacuate don't know so just to  send that message a lot of your homes  are still standing ours didn't make it  but sometimes it happens you're right  you're gonna rebuild huh you rebuild  yeah we love this area we love the  people here we love this neighborhood  and luckily some of the property is  still intact you know just the home you  know it's funny you think that there you  see movies and you think they'll be one  doll leftover or a book or something I  mean there's just rubble there's nothing  left